so if you are doing that and you're  mailing gifts make sure you do it soon  the shipping deadlines are fast  approaching in fact today is the  deadline for ground shipping for most  major carriers  greeting cards have to be mailed by the  18th which is friday  and then from saturday onwards there are  still options you've got priority mail  select express overnight services  but they're more expensive and since  most of us are shopping online this year  industry analysts expect  about three billion packages are going  to be shipped between thanksgiving and  christmas  i have never seen a demand that is  at that high exceeding the capacity no  matter  which carrier you are some post offices  have extended their retail hours and  they've even added sunday service but  you should really prepare for possible  inventory issues and shipping snags  so get stuff in the mail or